[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا مساء الخير انا ميسون
الواهد واقدم لكم اخبار الساعه نبدا
بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
واشنطن تؤكد تضررا منظومه باتريوت في
اوكرانيا بقصف روسيا لكنها تؤكد ايضا انها
لا تزال تعمل
البرهان يستعرض قواته في الخرطوم
ومستشار حميتي يشترط من جنوب السودان وقف
النار للقاء الخصمين
بملفات عربيه ساخنه القاده العرب يستعدون
للمشاركه في قمه جده العربيه
والسلطات الفرنسيه تحاصر جماعه الاخوان
وتستهدف نحو 20 صندوقا ماليا يدعم تيارات
ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم البدايه من اوكرانيا وبالتحديد
الجدل حول تدمير منظومه صواريخ باتريوت
الامريكيه في قصف روسيا بكاز اعلان روسي
تبعه نفي اوكراني ثم تاكيد امريكي في
الاخير لكن هل تلقى السلاح الامريكي
الاشهر اول هزيمه امام السلاح الروسي على
اراضي كاف فبعد ان استطاعت القوات الروسيه
الحاق الضرر بمنظومه باتريوت ارادت واشنطن
ان تنهي بنفسها الجدل الذي اثير عن
الانباء المتضاربه حول تضرر الباتريات
الولايات المتحده ورغم اقرارها بتضرر
منظومتها قالت انها لا تزال تعمل
منك ينضم الي الان مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل حذيفه اهلا بك معنا هذا الجدل مازال
مستمرا منذ الامس هل من بيان رسمي من قبل
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تؤكد بانه لن
تستهدف هذه المنظومه وكيف للولايات
المتحده ان تؤكد ذلك
مساء الخير ميسون لا تعليق هو التصريح
الذي تصر عليه كييف على لسان يوري جنات
الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات الجويه ولكن
قناه ايضا اضاف في تصريح وتعليقه على هذه
الحادثه وحول اللقط الذي دار حول تدمير
منظومه باتريوت في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف
وقال ايضا انه لا يمكن تدمير منظومه
باتريوت بصاروخ واحد حتى وان كان الصاروخ
الفرد الصوتي من طراز كنجال او خنجر معروف
بخنجر وهذا ما اعتبره المراقبين انه
اعتراف ضمني بانه هناك اصابه قد وقعت
بالفعل على احدى منظومات في منطقه كيف
وطبعا ايضا تحدث على طبيعه عمل هذه
المنظومه وانها كيف تعمل والى اي مدى هي
محميه ولكن ايضا اصر وقال اننا لن نعلق
ولن نقول ماذا دمروا وكم دمروا هذا هو
موقفنا ولكن اعتبر المراقبين ما تحدث به
حول ان صاروخ حتى وان كان من تراث كنجا
للفرد صوتي انه لا يستطيع تدمير هذه
المنظومه انه شبه اعتراف ضني بانه هنالك
ضرر قد حدث بالفعل لاحدى منظومات الدفاع
الجوي الاوكرانيه طب بالنسبه ايضا
يبدو بانه يجب ان تبقى معي ساذهب الى بعض
الاخبار حذيفه ومن ثم اعود لمتابعه هذا
الموضوع والتطورات الاوكرانيه اذا
مشاهدينا كيف هزمت روسيا منظومه باتريوت
الامريكيه عمليه التدمير تم بواسطه صواريخ
الفرد صوتيه كنزال والتي تبلغ سرعتها عشره
اعضاف سرعه الصوت ورغم اطلاق منظومه
المضاده للصواريخ 32 صاروخا الا انها لم
تتمكن من اصابه الهدف ما يعكس عجز منظومه
الدفاع الامريكيه ويرجع نجاح صواريخ كنجعل
في مهامها بالاساس الى قدراتها العاليه
على المناوره ما يقلل من امكانيه اعتراضها
من انظمه الصواريخ المضاده للطائره
يجب ان نتذكر مقدار الجهد الذي كلفته مثل
هذه الاسلحه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا مقدار
الوقت والطاقه والحجج والاجتماعات والعمل
الذي سمح لنا ببناء مثل هذا النظام
الدفاعي الجوي هذا عمل هائل واشكر كل من
شارك فيه يوما بعد يوم وشهرا بعد شهر يعمل
فريقنا لضمان حصولنا على حمايه اجوائنا
اعتدنا ان نسمع ان حصولنا على صواريخ
باتريوت غير واقعيه والان ها هي باتريو
اعود مجددا الى زميلنا مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عبد الله حذيفه ابرز التطورات اليوم
على الجبهات وخاصه دائما العيون على بخموت
ومحيطها
اسمحي لي ان ابدا بباخ مت اعلنت السلطات
الاوكرانيه انها استطاعت ان تحقق تقدما
اليوم ايضا في الجبهه في جبهه باخموت
واستطعت ان تستعيد 500 متر اي نصف كيلو
متر في هذه الجبهه ايضا اعلنت عن قتل
حوالي 112 جنديه الروسيا ومئه سبعه وخمسين
او 153 عفوا قد اصيبوا من القوات الروسيه
في جبهه باخموت وتقول ان القتال شديد جدا
في هذه الجبهه وقوات الدفاع الاوكرانيه
حتى الان هي قادره على الصمود بل والتقدم
في هذه الجبهه طبعا اليوم كان هنالك عمليه
قصف حتى قبل قليل يعني قبل اقل من نصف
ساعه كان هنالك عمليه قصف جديده نحو مدينه
اوديسا ولكن قبلها ايضا كان في خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه وخاصه من بعد الظهر وحتى
المساء كان هنالك ضربات نفذت براجمات
الصواريخ على مدينه خرسون حتى ان الرئيس
فلاديمير زيليسكي خاصه القصف الذي حدث في
خرسون بال وعده ولايات اخرى وذكر تحديدا
احد الاطفال الذين قتلوا في اخرسون فلوت
وهو طفل يبلغ من العمر السادسه قتل في هذا
القصف في مدينه خرس في ولايه خرسون ولكن
ايضا القسط طال اوبلس مدينه وايضا
من الولايات كما ان السلطات الاوكرانيه
تقول ان القوات الروسيه كثفت القصف على
الولايات الحدوديه وخاصه منطقه شررميغا
منطقه سومي ومنطقه
بالنسبه لكيف بالامس كنت معنا حذيفه وكان
هناك اخبار عاجله على موضوع اعلان الحاله
القصوى
وكانت سماء كيف ايضا بالامس مشتعله ماذا
عن ما جرب الامس هل ايضا كان هناك اي بيان
يشرح ما جرب الامس
الاهداف اين كانت
نعم في الحقيقه تم توجيه خمسه صواريخ نحو
العاصمه كيف تم تدميرها كذلك تم توجيه عده
صواريخ في اتجاه الغرب والاوكراني كذلك
اعلنت السلطات انها استطعت ان تدمر هذه
الصواريخ المناطق التي حدث فيها ضرطه عن
الضربه كانت شامله في عده ولايات المناطق
التي حدث فيها ضرر هي كانت
في منطقه دونيسك نفسها في كروماتورسكو وفي
ايضا سلوفانك وفي شاصيار هذه المناطق التي
حدث فيها الضرر واستطاعت بعض الاهداف ان
تصلوا
ايضا حدث فيها انفجار وخرسون ايضا حدث في
انفجار اما كيف فلم تصل اي من الاهداف الى
العاصمه شكرا لك منك يا مراسل العربيه
حذيفه عادل
رغم دعوتها لتشكل تحالف دولي لتزويد
الكافي مقاتلات افسته عشر قال وزير الدفاع
البريطاني ان بلاده لن تتبرع في الوقت
الحالي باي طائرات مقاتله لاوكرانيا
اعتقد ان هذا هو المفتاح ان ترسل بريطانيا
والمانيا رساله الى روسيا مفردها ان ما
تقوم به امر غير مقبول ينبغي عليها البحث
عن بدائل وترك اوكرانيا لن تتبرع بريطانيا
باي طائرات مقاتله لاوكرانيا في هذا الوقت
ما يمكننا المساهمه به بوضوح هو تقديم
التدريب والدعم المهم حقا هنا هو ارسال
اشاره الى روسيا باننا كدول ليس لدينا اي
اعتراض على تزويد كياف بالقدرات القتاليه
التي تحتاجها اعتمادا على ما يجري في ساحه
المعركه
اما المجاري التي تربطها علاقات قويه مع
الكريم
الاوروبي لاوكرانيا حتى تقوم الاخيره برفع
بنكبي من قائمه رعاه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا واضاف وزير خارجيه المجر ان
بلاده لن تسمح بالافراج عن 500 مليون يورو
من مرفق السلام الاوروبي تابع للاتحاد
والمخصصه لنقل الاسلحه لاوكرانيا حتى
تغيير وضعيه البيت
[موسيقى]
حول مساعر الصين للعب دور في الازمه اكد
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني ديمتروكوليبا
للمبعوث الصيني ضروره احترام وحده الاراضي
الاوكرانيه واسيادتها كما اكد على اهميه
دور الصين في انهاء الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا مضيفا ان اوكرانيا لن تقبل اي
مقترحات تحمل احتماليه خساره اراض
اوكرانيه
[موسيقى]
وبعد مفاوضات متعثره اعلن الرئيس التركي
رضا الطيب اردوغان تمديد اتفاق تصدير
الحبوب بين روسيا واوكرانيا لمده شهرين
اضافيين برعايه الامم المتحده
سولو كانت مده التمديد الاخير على وشك
الانتهاء بفضل جهود بلادنا وبدعم من
اصدقائنا الروس والاوكرانيين تم الاتفاق
على تمديد اتفاقيه ممر حبوب البحر الاسود
لمده شهرين
وفي ردود الفعل على تمديد صفقه الحبوب
اكدت روسيا تمديد الاتفاق لكنها طالبت
بتصحيح تطبيق الاتفاق الذي وصفته بغير
المتوازن اما اوكرانيا فاربت عن امتنانها
بتمديد الاتفاق مؤكده ضروره عدم السماح
لروسيا بعرقلته واستخدام الغذاء وسيله
للابتزاز على حد التعبير مسؤول اوكراني
اما الامم المتحده فرحبت بتمديد الاتفاق
حيث اكد الامين العام انطونيو غوتيريش
اهميه هذا الاتفاق على الامن الغذائي
العالمي
هناك تطورات ايجابيه ملحوظه وهي تاكيد
روسيا على تمديد اتفاق البحر الاسود
للستين يوما انا ارحب بهذا القرار وهو خبر
جيد للعالم كله القضايا المعلقه باقيه لكن
ممثلي روسيا واوكرانيا وتركيا والامم
المتحده سيستمرون في مناقشتها امل ان
نتوصل الى اتفاق شامل لتحسين وتوسيع
المبادره كما اقترحت في رساله اخيره الى
رؤساء البلدان الثلاثه
وحول المنظومه الامريكيه في كافي ينضم الي
من واشنطن الان طبعا ضيفنا من واشنطن
نتحدث معه ماي كاميل روي نائب مساعده وزير
الدفاع الامريكيه السابق سنتحدث معه عن
هذا الاستهداف اهلا بك سيد ميدروي بالنسبه
لهذا الاستهداف منظومه الامريكيه التي تعد
من اقوى الاسلحه الامريكيه كيف يمكن ان
تستهدف من الجيش الروسي
يسعدني ان اكون معكم ومع المشاهدين لا
اعلم تماما اذا ما كانت روسيا قد قامت
فعلا بتدمير منظومه
وفقا لمزاعمها الاخرى التي نسمعها
باستمرار من الجانب الروسي
اعتقد انه لا يجب ان تؤخذ الكلمه بقيمتها
الحقيقيه الا الى حين رؤيه المزيد من
الادله من الجانب الاوكراني هو خلال
الايام القليله القادمه اعتقد اننا سوف
نعلم اذا ما كان هناك اي ضرر قد اصاب
بنظام فتره الذي تم نشره لاوكرانيا لكن
اقول
بان هذا الامر يعد جللا ومهما كبيرا لان
هذه المنظومه تعدل اكثر تعقيدا وتطورا في
العالم واي خساره تلحق بها سوف تكون كبيره
ولكن في المعركه يحتمل وجود هذا الامر وفي
المرحله الحاليه لا نعلم اذا ما كان قد تم
تدمير هذه المنظومه واذا ما تم ذلك كيف
فعل الروس ذلك قد يكونوا ان انظمه الرادار
الخاصه بهذا بهذه المنظومه لا تزال تعمل
حتى اللحظه السيد من راي الولايات المتحده
اقرت بان هذه المنظومه قد
استهدفت ولكن ايضا قالت بانها ما زالت
تعمل هل يعد هذا اخفاق امريكي وما هي
تداعياته
لقد اقرت الولايات المتحده باستهداف
منظومه باتريوت للدفاع الجوي
واعلموا وكنا نعلم بانه سوف تستهدف
وخاصه
بان ندرك بان هذه المنظومه متعدده في
المكونات سوف تقوم
بالتصدي لكافه الصواريخ الروسيه وسوف يكون
لها اثر في التخفيف من حده الضربات
الموجهه على البنى التحتيه
ولا يمكن حتى لصواريخ الفرض الصوتيه انت
ان تقوم باستهدافه
لكن لو كان قد تمس اهدافها فسوف يتم تقييم
الامر
وهذا الامر سوف يكون متوقع
لكن هذا لا يعني بان الاوكرانيين لم
يقوموا بتشغيل تلك المنظومه بطريقه صحيحه
رغم ان كانت كل الاحتياطات ترمي بعدم بعدم
توجيه اي ضربه اليها وخاصه اذا ما كانت
الاصابه قد الحقت اضرارا بتلك المنظومه
شكرا لكم واشنطن نائب مساعد وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه السابق
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات اردوغان
يهاجم المعارضه ويقول انها لا تنسلك
مشروعا واضحا ومنافسه يرد سنقاتل حتى
الفوز
[موسيقى]
نتابع اخبار الساعه من السودان حيث تجددت
الاشتباكات في الخرطوم وسط بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع ورصد مراسل العربيه
تحليقا مكثفا لطيران الجيش والسماع اصوات
مضادات ارضيه لقوات الدعم السريع مراسل
العربيه افاد بان الاشتباكات تمت بالاسلحه
الخفيفه في كبري حي الفتحاب
[موسيقى]
ومع احتدام المعارك ظهر رئيس مجلس السياده
السودانيه عبد الفتاح البرهان من جنود
القوات المسلحه امام مقر قياده القوات
البريه في العاصمه الخرطوم على ما يبدو
اراد البرهان استعراض قواته مع غياب قائد
الدعم السريع متي منذ ثلاثه اسابيع عن
الانظار ويعد هذا احدث ظهور البرهان منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات مع قوات الدعم السريع
الصور تشير الى ان ظهور البرهان كان في
محيط مطار الخرطوم حيث تدور المعارك بين
طرفي الصراع منذ بدايه الازمه
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء قال مستشار قائد قوات الدعم
السريع للشؤون السياسيه يوسف عزت بان حمتي
مستعد للقاء البرهان في اي زمان ومكان
يختاره البسطاء بشرط وقف اطلاق النار
مشيرا في نفس الوقت الى ان الدعم السريع
سيطر على نحو 90% من مناطق الخرطوم وبان
الحرب الدائره تخللها عمل دعائي كبير من
قبل الطرف الاخر كما نفع عزت على هامش
لقائه رئيس جنوب السداس الباكارميه
الاخبار المتداوله بشان استخدام الدعم
السريع المواطنين كدروع بشريه
عمق القتال المستمر بين طرفي الصراع
الازمه الانسانيه حيث بات يحتاج نحو 25
مليون شخص اي اكثر من نصف السكان الى
مساعده انسانيه عاجله تقدر الامم المتحده
اكثر من ثلاثه مليارات دولار حجم
المساعدات التي يحتاج اليها السودان اما
الفارينه من الصراع فهناك توقعات امنيه
بان يتجاوز عددهم المليون هذا العام حيث
ستحتاج الامم المتحده الى 470 مليون دولار
اضافيه لمساعده هؤلاء بعد ان اصبحوا بلا
ماوى
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم ينضم الي الصحفيه عمار ابو
شيبه عمار اهلا بك معنا اين تركز القصف
اليوم
والاشتباكات والوضع الان في هذه اللحظات
في الخرطوم
نعم الوضع الان يشير الى حاله من الهدوء
بشكل كبير في عدد من الاحياء التي دارت
فيها
اشتباكات خفيفه اليوم يمكن ان نصنفه بان
الاشتباكات فيه خفيفه بعكس ما كان بالامس
كانت هنالك اشتباكات ما بين القوات
المتواجده في الارض في منطقه الجيل
الشمالي بحري والطيران الذي قصفت تلك
المناطق بكثافه ايضا في منطقه ام درمان
كانت هنالك اشتباكات في منطقه الفتحه لم
تستمر طويلا وفي منطقه الخرطوم هنا دارت
اشتباكات في عدد من الاحياء منها جبرا
والصحافه ومنطقه الخرطوم ثلاثه هذه
الاشتباكات لم تستمر كثيرا ربما هي
اشتباكات خفيفه ومناوشات ما بين القوات
المتواجده في الارض سلاح الطيران هنا في
منطقه شرق العاصمه الخرطوم ووسط العاصمه
الخرطوم وجنوب العاصمه الخرطوم لم تكن له
طلعت جويه مكثفه كانت هنالك طلعت لطائرات
الاستطلاع ولكنها ايضا لم
طويلا هذا كله ياتي بالتزامن مع ما جرى من
معارك عنيفه وقويه جدا في وسط العاصمه
الخرطوم ومنطقه بحري وحتى مدينه ام درمان
ولكن الوضع الان فيه نسبه كبيره من الهدوء
والهدوء والحذر عمار ما هي ردود الفعل على
ظهور السيد البرهان بين الجنود بين القوات
البريه ان كان من قبل السودانيين
المواطنين وايضا من قبل المراقبين
والاحزاب السياسيه هل هناك من رساله اراد
ان يوجهها من خلال هذا الظهور
نعم هذه الرساله الاولى هي موجهه للجنود
في عدد كبير من الخنادق وعدد كبير جدا من
الارتكازات العسكريه للجيش وايضا كذلك في
عده مناطق ومعسكرات باعتبار ان المعركه
دخلت في شهرها ثاني كان لابد بحسب عدد من
الاراء العسكريه للقائد العام ان يظهر في
ارض الميدان وان يقود هذه القوات برسمه
وهو ظهر كذلك بلباس العسكري والسلاحه
الشخصي وفي منطقه القوات البريه التي كان
يراسها في العام 18 والفين قبل ان ياتي
الى رئاسه المجلس العسكري في ابريل العام
19 ومن ثم رئيسا للمجلس السيادي في ذات
العام هنالك رسائل اخرى ايضا كذلك للمجتمع
الخارجي كانت هنالك ربما مصادر دبلوماسيه
اشارت الان السفير الحاج سيمثل البرهان في
قمه القمه المزمعه قيامها في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وان البرهان لن يستطيع
المشاركه ربما هنا ايضا كذلك رساله بانه
قادر على اداره المعركه او مشغولا هذه
المعارك على ارض الميدان هنالك رساله ايضا
للجانب الاخر لقوات الدعم السريع باعتباره
انه موجود الان ويقود القوات ويتحرك في
محيط القياده العامه للجيشه التي دارت
فيها اشتباكات حتى الامس في منطقه قريبه
في شارع افريقيا شارع المطار لم تكن بعيده
وفرض فيها الدعم السريع السيطره منطقه
واحد وستين العمارات حيث تتواجد معسكرات
للقوه الجويه الاركان وايضا فرع الرياضه
العسكري هنا اشاره ايضا مجتمعيه تفاعل
معها الناس بشكل واضح من خلال المجتمع
الاسفوري والرسائل الالكترونيه وما فيها
تداول هذه الصور والفيديوهات بكثافه
البرهان وهنالك من ذهب الى كثير جدا من
التعليقات فيما يخص ظهور هذا القائد في
هذا التوقيت شكرا لك من الخطوبه الصحفيه
عمار ابو شيبه على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
[موسيقى]
وما زالت العيون شاخصه على تركيا وتحديدا
على الانتخابات اردوغان وكليتش دار اوغلو
المتنافسان قررا طي صفحه الجوله الاولى
ويصبان كل تركيزهما على الجوله الثانيه
الحاسمه المرشحان المتبقيان سابقان الزمن
لتصحيحها فوات الجوله الاولى
مرشح تحالف الامه ساره لاعاده ترتيب
اوراقه من خلال اجراء التعديلات جوهريه
لفريق حملته الانتخابيه زعيم المعارضه اقل
مديري حملته الانتخابيه اكان الدوله وعلي
كراميتي اوغلو وعين منافس اردوغان بدلا
منهما رئيسه فرع حزب الشعب الجمهوري في
اسطنبول جنان
بالاضافه الى الرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم
امام اوغلو صاحب الشعبيه الكبيره
يبدو انك ايضا يلعب على ملف اللاجئين في
محاوله لتجاوز ورطه انقسام المعارضه مرشح
وحزب الشعب الجمهوري قال انه سيقاتل حتى
الفوز بالانتخابات
انا اخاطب الجميع لم نجد هذا الوطن في
الشارع لن نترك وطننا للعقليه التي سمحت
بدخول عشره ملايين مهاجر غير نظامي بيننا
ايها الشباب انهضوا وتخلصوا من ذلك الياس
الذي يخيم عليكم اولئك الذين يحبون وطنهم
سياتون الى صناديق الاقتراع سنقاتل حتى
النهايه وسنفوز بالتاكيد
على الطرف الاخر يستعد اردوغان للجوله
الثانيه بثقه اكبر وهو ما حاول اظهاره في
خطاباته التي تلت الجوله الاولى اردوغان
بدا متاكده من قدرته على حسم جوله الاعاده
وهو ما عبر عنه في تغريده قال فيها ان
الوقت حان لتتويج النجاح الذي تحقق في
الجوله الاولى بفوز اكبر اردوغان هاجم
المعارضه وقال انها لا تمتلك رؤيه او
مشروعا واضحا
واثقون من الفوز بالجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات وبفارق كبير
اكثر مما راينا وكما نقول دائما مشكله
المعارضه بتركيا انها لا تمتلك رؤيه او
برنامجا او مشروعا لقد غيرنا كل شيء في
بلادنا لكن للاسف لم نتمكن من تغيير
المعارضه لكننا نعتقد ان هذه الانتخابات
ستؤدي الى التغيير الذي ينتظره الجميع منذ
سنوات
من اسطنبول لا ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي
سيد جواد اهلا بك معنا هذه التعديلات وهذا
التغيير الذي قام به السيد كليتش دار
اوغلو لقاده حملته الانتخابيه هل هو دليل
على انه ما زال يعول بان هذه الوجوه
الجديده وخاصه
من الممكن ان يحدث مفاجاه وتكون النتيجه
ايجابيه له
تحيه لمشاهدنا الكرام طبعا اليوم بداوا
بالدعايه للجوله الثانيه بكثافه وبقوه
مثلا سالوا انه عندما كسب السيد اردوغان
49.5% لماذا لا يصر على
اعاده العد والفرز حتى يصل الى خمسين
بالمئه اشاره ان هناك تزوير او تلاعب في
نتائج الانتخابات وغير ذلك بالنتيجه هناك
خطوات ننتظر من كمال كوليسترول مثلا ان
يعلن مرشح للوزراء اذا صاروا حكومه فمن هو
وزير الاقتصاد سوف يكون او وزير الخارجيه
مثلا مثل هذه الوزارات المهمه او وزير
الدفاع وغير ذلك حتى ياتي
الناس تجذب الناس لاعاده انتخاب
كمال كليتشار اوغلو
طبعا هناك شخصيات مهمه جدا في تركيا نحن
بلد 35
80 مليون
كثير من القدرات
واكاديميين وشخصيات يعني عندهم اهليه
لجميع المناصب في الحكومه لكن معزولين
بسبب انهم ليسوا مقربين من حزب الحاكم
الان
غدا الساعه 11 هناك اجتماع سداسي كما
الكوليسترول مع خمسه قيادات من الاحزاب
الاخرى للاعلان وانهم اعلنوا ان كل هؤلاء
ورؤساء الاحزاب سوف يكونون في صناديق
الاقتراع يعني اشكالات كانت موجهه على
قيادات حزب الشعب الجمهوري انه انتم لا
تتمسكون بصناديق الاقتراع وغير ذلك ايضا
هناك مفاوضات كانت بين كمال كردستان طبعا
السيناريوه
بعد قال بعد غد في 19 مايو سوف يعلنوا
لصالحه
ولكن ايضا سنتحدث عن موضوع اصداء هذه
الانتخابات التركيه التي تمتد الى دول
الجوار الاوروبيه فطبعا مشاهدينا اوروبا
التي تتقاسم الجغرافيا مع تركيا تراقب عن
كثب ما ستسفر عنه هذه الجوله فما هي
الملفات الاوروبيه التي ترتبط بنتيجه هذه
الانتخابات طبعا تاتي في طلعتها مساله
انضمام السويد الى حلف الناتو صحيفه
في حال فوز اردوغان الصحيفه توقعت ايضا ان
يستغل اردوغان هذه الورقه من اجل الضغط
على واشنطن وحلفائها على الطرف الاخر فان
مخاوف السويد قد تتبدد في حاله فوزك
لتشدار اوغلو فالمعارضه تبدو اكثر ليونه
في التعامل مع المطالب الاوروبيه ايضا
العلاقات التجاريه والدبلوماسيه الاوروبيه
التركيه قد تتاثر بشكل كبير في حال فوز
احد الطرفين كيف تبدو فرص عقد شركات
اقتصاديه مهمه الى جانب الغاء التاشيرات
للمواطنين الاتراك تبدو اقوى في حال فوز
اوغلو فالاخير قد يستجيب بشكل اكبر لشروط
الاتحاد الاوروبي من قبل بل من قبل اطلاق
سراح السجناء السياسيين والالتزام
باستقلاليه القضاء وهي شروط لم يبدع
اردوغان
استعدادا كبيرا للاستجابه اليها كما ان
فوزه من شانه ان يفتح المجال امام
الاستثمارات الاوروبيه عكس اردوغان الذي
يبدو اكثر تحفظا
من جديد الى اسطنبول مع المحلل السياسي
جواد جوجو السيد جواد طبعا البعض يعتبر
بانه سيد السنان هو الذي سيكون كما يقال
بيضه القبان التي
ستعطي الارجحيه لاردوغان او لكما ولكن
هناك موضوع ملف اللاجئين ما زالتجار اوغلو
متمسكا فيه هل اعطى هذا الملف هل كان ورقه
رابحه خلال الجوله الاولى ولماذا ما زال
متمسكا فيه
والسريعا ان ترحلهم هذه الخلافات لا زالت
بينهما موجوده لكن بصراحه
سنان اوغان يحاسب حساباته لمستقبل سياسته
ولهذا السبب هو سوف يبقى محايدا كما يبدو
ان على اتباعه ان يصاب لاي جهه من الجهات
اللي يريدون شكرا لك المحلل السياسيه
من اسطنبول
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات مبنى
البرلمان البريطاني مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بشان القمه العربيه في
جده المقرر عقدها الجمعه ينتظر القاده
العرب ملفات ساخنه عده ابرزها الملف
السوري الازمه في السودان ليبيا وتطورات
الاوضاع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه وعلى هامش
الاجتماع التحضيري لوزراء خارجيات العرب
الذي عقد اليوم في جده قالت الخارجيه
السعوديه ان الوزير الامير فيصل بن فرحان
التقى نظيره السوري فيصل المقداد على هامش
الاجتماع التحضيري للقمه العربيه في جده
وبحث معه مستجدات الاوضاع على الساحه
السوريه والقضايا ذات الاهتمام المشترك
وكان وزير الخارجيه السعودي رحب بعوده
سوريا لشغل مقعدها في الجامعه
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم اصحاب السوء والمعالي يمر عالمنا
اليوم بتحديات وصعوبات عديده تجعلنا امام
مفترق طرق تحتم علينا الوقوف صفا واحدا
وبذل المزيد من الجهد لتعزيز العمل العربي
المشترك من اجل مواجهتها وايجاد الحلول
المناسبه لها لتصبح منطقه امنه ومستقره
تنعم بالخير والرفاه ان منطقه العربيه
تسخر بطاقات بشريه وثروات طبيعيه تجعلنا
امام تحدي مع انفسنا يفرض علينا جميعا
التنسيق المستمر وتسخير كافه الادوات
الممكنه وتفعيل الابتكار الات عمل الجديده
نابدين خلافتنا البينيه رافضين التدخلات
والخارجيه واضعين نصب اعيننا مصالح دولنا
وشعوبنا من اجل تحقيق نهضه شامله طالما
تطلعت اليها شعوبنا
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد في تصريحات للعربيه ان سوريا لا
يمكن ان تغيب عن اي قمه عربيه مقبله
ونحن سنرحب باي دور ستقوم بالدول العربيه
في هذا المجال
سيكون رئيس السوري متواجدا في
كما جرت العاده السوريه لا يمكن ان تغيب
عن اي قمه
كما قلت لا يمكن لسوريا ان تغيب عن اي قمه
سنوات عجاف بلغ عدد اثنتي عشره سنه رفرف
خلالها العلم السوري وحيدا ثم جاءت السنه
التي اغيثت فيه العلاقات السوريه العربيه
ليتوسط العلم السوري اعلام باقي الدول
المشكله للمنظمه من جديد الموعد قمه جده
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان رحب بمشاركه الوفد السوري في دوره
القمه العربيه الثانيه والثلاثين
وانتهز هذه الفرصه للترحيب بمشاركه
الجمهوريه العربيه السوريه في اجتماعنا
اليوم
ترحيب كبير من دمشق بالعوده للحضن العربي
السعوديه بذلت جهد هائل من اجل تحسين
الاجواء العربيه ومن اجل
احتضان جميع الدول العربيه ونحن ممتنون ان
كل الدول العربيه الان موجوده في هذه
القمه المقعد لم يعد شاغرا وسوريا ابرز
الحاضرين
ترحب الجزائر ايما ترحيب
ببوادر تكريس هذا التوجه
الذي بدات تتجلى
ملامحه مع استئناف الجمهوريه العربيه
السوريه
الشقيقه شغله مقعدها بمنظمتنا عوده تنظر
منها الجامعه تفاعلا سوريا بناء وايجابيا
وفق ما جاء على لسان الامين العام احمد
ابو الغيط واتمنى ان تكون استعاده سوريا
لمقعدها مقدمه لانهاء ازمتها
والاستعادتها لحيويتها وحضورها في العمل
العربي عوده سوريا الى حضنها العربي اهم
حدث قبل انعقاد القمه قمه ينظر اليها
مراقبون باعتبارها فرصه لمناقشه ابرز
القضايا التي تهم المنطقه العربيه بلال
الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
قالت صحيفه الفرنسيه ان باريس ستضيق
الخناقه على جماعه الاخوان وتضربهم على
المستوى المالي المرتبط بالجمعيات التابعه
للتنظيم الصحيفه اضافت ان نحو 20 صندوقا
تابعا لاوقاف وتبرعات تم تحديدها
باعتبارها مشكوكا بارتباطها بتيار متطرف
فرنسا ليتم تجميد ما يقرب من 25 مليون
يورو في مختلف صناديق الهبات التابعه
لتنظيم الاخوان
ما تزال جماعه الاخوان في فرنسا والتنظيم
العالي الذي تعمل به موضع اهتمام اجهزه
الاستخبارات الفرنسيه صحيفه لوفيجارو كشفت
عن قيام المديريه العامه للامن الداخلي
بتحديد صناديق اوقاف مرتبطه بالجماعه تقوم
باستثمار غير قانوني لاموال تصرف على
نشاطاتها هذه التحقيقات افضل الى تجميد ما
يقرب من 25 مليون يورو كانت مجموعه في 20
صندوق هبات انشئت عام 2008 وعملت على
اخفاء دوائر تمويل الجماعه لحظ ان هناك
تاخر من قبل السلطات الفرنسيه لسببين سبب
الاول
شيء من السذاجه في ادراك خطوره هذا
المنهاج ثانيا الزابونيه السياسيه في
فرنسا التي تشجع
كسب اصوات الناخبين المسلمين
الطويله والدقيقه التي تم اجراؤها من قبل
اجهزه الاستخبارات الفرنسيه تكشف عن اليه
تمويل غامضه ومعقده بشده لكنها سمحت في
النهايه بتنفيذ ما اسمتها الصحيفه اجراءات
عرقله في غايه السريه واستهدفت حتى الان
ثمانيه صناديق من اصل الصناديق العشرين هي
تستفيد من المنظومه الفرنسيه
مثلا في التمويل العامه مثلا في حملات
لمكافحه اسلاموفوبيا لكن في المقابل يلجا
المستهدفون بهذه الاجراءات الى مسارات
قضائيه واحيانا الى توظيف علاقات سياسيه
مع مسؤولين من اقصى اليسار ويضحضون
علاقاتهم مع الجماعه بالقول انهم ضحايا
حملتك كراهيه تشنها اجهزه من الدوله
الفرنسيه
وحدد جهاز الاستخبارات الاقليميه نحو 10
مدن اظهرت ما تسميها مذكرات استخبار اتيه
اشارات مبكره على التطرف هذه المدن تشهد
نشاطات مختلفه لجماعه الاخوان على محور
يمتد من مارسيليا جنوبيه البلاد مرورا
بالعاصمه باريس ووصولا الى مدينه ليل
الشماليه فرنسا
فدهوك العربيه باريس
[موسيقى]
معك عزيز الصيني بوجودها في المنطقه قال
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي ان الولايات
المتحده مهتمه بموقعها في منطقه المحيط
الهادئ والهندي مضيفا ان الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن سيلتقي جميع قاده جزر المحيط
الهادئ في العام الجاري
[موسيقى]
لكن مشاهدينا ما يقلق واشنطن حقا هو تنامي
التعاون الروسي الايراني واذا كانت طهران
وموسكو لا تخفيان تعاونهما فان واشنطن لم
تكف عن ابداء تخوفاتها في اخر مظاهر هذا
التعاون توقيع روسيا لاتفاق يقضي بتمويل
وانشاء خط للسكك الحديديه في ايران ليكون
جزءا من خطط اقامه ممر نقل دولي يربط بين
الشمال والجنوب الرئيس الروسي نفسه اشرف
على هذا التوقيع عبر اتصال مرئي مع الرئيس
الايراني هذا التعاون الايراني الروسي
يشمل ايضا التعاون العسكري الذي يشكل رقما
مهما في هذه المعادله تعاون وتنسيق عسكري
برزان مجددا خلال لقاء جمع قائد البحريه
الايرانيه شهران ايراني بنظيره الروسي
نيكولايز في طهران لقاء دعا خلاله قائد
سلاح البحريه الايرانيه بشكل صريح الى
تعزيز التعاون مع روسيا من جانبه اعرب ق
الروسيه عن تطلعه لان تسهم زيارته لطهران
في تعميق التعاون الثنائي
واشنطن لم تتردد اذا في ابداء قلقها
الشديد من هذا التعاون المتزايد بين موسكو
وهران البيت الابيض قال ان لديه ما يكفي
من المؤشرات التي تؤكد ان روسيا توسعان
شركتهما الدفاعيه واضاف ان هذا التعاون قد
يساعد موسكو على اطاله امد حربها في
اوكرانيا من جهه وقد يشكل من جهه اخرى
تهديدا على جيراني ايران
قال نواب في بريطانيا ان مبنى البرلمان
الذي يعد تحفه معماريه واحد مواقع التراث
العالمي لليونسكو ويزوره مليون شخص سنويا
يواجه خطر الانهيار
مبنى البرلمان هذا على ضفافه نهر تيمز
والمطل على ساعه بيغ بن من المعالم
التاريخيه الشهيره في العالم وواجهه
سياحيه لملايين السياح من كل مكان لكن هذا
الصرح مهدد بالانهيار
[موسيقى]
فتقرير للجنه المحاسبه العامه بمجلس
العموم التي تدقق في مصاريف البرلمان خلص
بان خطه الترميم المبنى الواجب اعتمادها
بطيئه في التعامل مع احداث من تسرب المطر
من السقف وسقوط قطع من البناء الى الجدران
الملوث بماده المدرب بصحه العاملين بداخله
والحرائق المتفرقه هذا بشهادات مسؤولين
على الترميم وتجديد البرلمان المعروف بقصر
ويسمستر في افاداتهم امام اللجنه
البرلمانيه المعنيه
امن ولكنهم متداعن في مناطق رئيسيه معينه
وبحاجه ماسه الى الترميم ومن اجل الحفاظ
على سلامته على سبيل المثال من خطر نشوب
حريق كارثي يتعين علينا القيام بدوريات
عديده حيث ليس لدينا نظام قوي لمن اندلاع
الحرائق وانتشارها
لجنه المحاسبه تلوم سنوات من المماط له
بعد تحديد مجلس النواب قبل خمس سنوات
لمسار العمل الذي يكلف مليوني جنيه
استرليني في الاسبوع على مدى سبعه اعوام
وخاصه النواب الذين يرفضون الانتقال الى
مباني اخرى ما سيرفع تكلفه الترميم وصيانه
المبنى الى اكثر من 20 مليارا ويستغرق
عشرات السنين اذا استمرت الجلسه الصاخبه
في البرلمان اثناء عمليه الترميم
بريطانيا ام البرلمانات في العالم وواجهه
البلاد في الخارج بنيته التحتيه تتاكل وقد
يتعرض للتدمير قبل اصلاحه ما لم يتوقف
المسؤولون والنواب عن تجاوز المسؤوليه
بشان مخاوف التكاليف الباهضه لعمليه
الترميم في زمن التقشف مصطفى زاروا
العربيه لندن
تعرض لن يظهر وزوجته ميجانا لمطارده
سيارتهما اثناء التتبع المصورين لهما بعد
حفل خير في نيويورك وقال مكتبهما في بيان
ان المطارده استمرت اكثر من ساعتين
والسيارات شارفت على التصادم اكثر من مره
واصفا الحادثه بانها شبه كارثيه
ختام اخبار الساعه نذكر بالعناوين
واشنطن تؤكد وتضررا منظومه باتريوس في
اوكرانيا بقصر روسي لكنها تؤكد انها لا
تزال تعمل
البرهان يستعرض قواته في الخرطوم ومستشار
حميتي يشترط من جنوب السودان وقف النار
للقاء الخصمين
بملفات عربيه ساخنه القاده العربي يستعدون
للمشاركه في قمه جدا العربيه
والسلطات الفرنسيه تحاصر جماعه الاخوان
وتستهدف نحو 20 صندوقا ماليا يدعم تيارات
ارهابيه
اشكر لكم طبل متابعه نلتقي بعد قليل في
موجز للاخبار من العربيه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات